Here is two more examples of class rectangles describing
classes in a in a system.
On the left is the rectangle class.
It has two instance variables describing points.
These might be, for example, the upper left-hand corner or
lower right-hand corner.
The particular instance variables attributes have names p1 and p2.
And they have types point which presumably you've also declared in
your UML model.
In the operation section, there are three groups of operations,
each group is separated by a stereotype.
You can see the stereotypes because they
appear within the double angle brackets.
For example, at the top, there's a stereotype for
constructor, in the middle there's one for
query operations, and at the bottom there's one for update operations.
Within the, those three groups,
there's obviously going to be a constructor operation.
There's query operations for giving the area, and the aspect ratio
of the rectangle, and they're going to return real numbers.
Real is a primitive type within UML.
And at the bottom we have update operations for moving and
scaling the rectangle.
On the right is the reservation class.
You notice things are a little different here.
We don't have any attributes.
We begin initially with operations, and
then we have two additional horizontal units.
One for responsibilities and one for exceptions.
Note specifically that the words operations, responsibilities and
exceptions here are not part of UML.
They're just here to show you what the boxes are being used for.